welcome back to
welcome back welcome back to
the
next day in the morning session
we're absolutely delighted to have
raluka who is giving us a talk now
reluca is a faculty member at berkeley
she works in system security and applied
cryptography
she has done some really cool really
amazing work
very high impact she has co-founded
multiple startups which i believe are
doing really well
she has a long list of awards
the grace hopper award a best thesis
award at mit sloan research award
mit technology reviews 35 under 35. oh
you're memorized
i said that's so impressive i was like
if you go google for her you like read a
lot more really interesting uh
stuff about reluca so anyways i'll give
it over to her and we're all excited to
hear what you have to say thanks supangi
can you hear hear me well okay great so
yeah as chebanki mentioned my work is
more applied in building secure systems
with the help of crypto theory
and i chose this work in particular
because the core of this system is i
would say uh understandable for a more
general theory audience because i know
many of you here don't actually come
from a cryptography background so
hopefully it's understandable even
without crypto background
uh so basically in this work we're
trying to address um a long-standing
issue with oblivious storage the fact
that it doesn't scale and i'll explain
what that means but basically it has
been having a scalability bottleneck for
you know more than 20 years since we had
the initial protocols
and we managed in this work to basically
overcome it and manage to have an
obligatory system that can actually
scale
so
first question is why did we call our
system snoopy
um so snoopy stands for scalable notes
for oblivious object repository
[Laughter]
my symptom is slightly embarrassed here
but really the the one of the main
reason actually is that emma loves
calling her systems wildo dory snoopy
and you got a theme
sorry am i putting you on the spot so am
i here
and the other student vivian is an
excellent logo designer and graphic
designer so she did this original logo
and you'll see in the talk all the
people and dogs are her original artwork
um
but you know more and if even vivian
couldn't be here today because she's in
italy presenting a night to cali or smp
and she won the best paper there so
she's busy but really the credit goes to
the two of them they've done the hard
work on this on this paper
all right
so um i'm going to very quickly motivate
what oblivious storage is for those of
you who are not familiar for those of
you who know it i'm going to go pretty
fast through it
so you might have heard of end-to-end
encryption basically we want to encrypt
let me use this
i want to encrypt the data at a you know
sensitive data to server like for
example a medical disease store such
that if an attacker breaks in they just
see encrypted data right
and they even whatsapp user sent and
encryption and many of the systems that
they use into an encryption and it's
called end to end because
the user is the only one that has the
key just the ends have the key to the
clip the data and intermediaries only
have encrypted data
and so you think that this provides you
know very very strong security
guarantees but you know it's not enough
because there's still
an amount of information leakage
to an attacker watching how the data is
accessed okay so the data is encrypted
but seeing the fact that object one is
fetched versus object two versus object
three
and just to give you a very quick
example about that is
let's say we all know it's a public
knowledge which diseases are more common
and kind of their relative occurrence in
particular cavity super common today
so an attacker knows this as well
and now an attacker is just going to
watch
which of these you know disease roads
are being accessed with what frequency
and let's say at the end of i know a day
there's this many accesses for each one
of them so just from that frequency it
can infer
that you know object one is covered
object is flu and object three is asthma
right and now patient charlie
comes to the doctor and
the doctor diagnoses charlie with kovid
so it accesses the covered record which
the attacker can see
and infer that charlie has copied okay
so basically the data was encrypted at
all times but just from which object was
accessed the attacker was able to infer
what diseased object has and then
naturally has that disease
all right
um
so there's been a long standing you know
line of work on so-called oblivious
storage which tries to address this
problem the idea is that the accesses
made
to
storage should look either like random
basically the trace of accesses should
be cryptographers call it you know
simulatable from some public knowledge
so you can create the same trace of
accesses or indistinguishable from just
knowing things like
how many requests there are in a trace
but not knowing anything about the data
right but you can think of this
intuitively as the accesses are either
either looking like completely random or
they're predefined according to
predefined schedule if you have this
many requests you're going to have this
predefined schedule of accessing the
data so your accesses are not going to
reveal anything about the data content
or the data ids okay that's what
basically oblivious storage does there's
a long line of really amazing work
improving different aspects of this
technology
but basically
many of these works have two pieces two
components an rm client and an auram
server and the orem client has a secret
and this oram client must be in a
trusted place so must be
at least somewhere where the attacker
cannot see this key
and then the attacker can observe the
oram server but all the accesses are
going to look like you know they don't
reveal anything about object id
random or in some case predefined
schedule
so for example when the doctor does a
look up for kovid what's going to happen
is there's going to be an interaction
between this oram client and orm server
accesses to doram server look many times
random or as i mentioned predefined
schedule and then the doctor gets back
um the
file of interest
an attacker has no clue about what was
accessed in fact even if you access
twice covered one after the other it
doesn't look like you're accessing the
same thing
all right so um
but now to actually deploy this setting
in the real world there has been a you
know
in the recent years a very common setup
among a number of systems and the setup
is to put not just the orang server in a
cloud but also for the orm client in a
cloud but it has to be inside the
hardware enclave because it has the
secret key that's not supposed to be
visible to the attacker
and this is very nice as a setup because
uh it first of all it solves the problem
of where do you put the oram client in
reality we don't it's not that easy for
us to have a trusted party somewhere you
know in some theory papers we say put it
at a trusted party but who's that
trusted party right many companies don't
have the ability to set up a cluster
have an administrator manage it all that
really hard work so they end up putting
it in the cloud right
anyways
but then the other problem that it
really helps is that this communication
between the client and the server is
very fast it's because it's in the same
cloud and it's not in different parts of
a wide area network so this setup has
been you know has had some success
um
in this way
so we're going to work in the same setup
okay so um in this work we don't really
care what enclave you're using so we're
not prescribing any enclave we don't
cleave an agnostic we're just leveraging
some very basic property that most
enclaves aim to provide
and that is
all the data that comes in and out of
the enclave is encrypted and
authenticated with the key that's inside
the hardware
and the only thing that the attacker
sees is basically accesses to memory
so it can actually see the addresses uh
and those are side channels and the
attacker can actually see those
addresses and we're going to make sure
that you know those accesses are also
oblivious okay so again the abstract
model here is that data comes in and out
encrypted from the enclave and the only
thing that the attacker can see is
basically of course the size the time
when they come in and out but also what
memory address each data is put at or
read from
so the access patterns
and there's a ton of enclaves these days
uh you know there's more and more
improvements and more and more enclaves
there's a bunch in industry like sjx cdx
nitron cliffs they're available in the
public cloud today and this kind of
deployments are happening as we speak
and there's also a number of academic
enclaves like mi6 keystone sanctum
commodore and many others and the
academic ones tend to be even cleaner
stronger guarantees and whatnot but in
this work we don't care about unclear
enclave
agnostic okay so in terms of the threat
model
it's quite standard
the cloud
could be compromised by a malicious
attacker that can see everything at the
cloud and can also modify everything
[Music]
so in particular can view all these
memory access patterns we talked about
that the enclave is making also network
communication in the cloud if you have
multiple machines how many messages get
sent between them so really it can see
everything
um but one thing i want to say is that
there's already a bunch of work that
exists on
preventing the attacker from modifying
anything and kind of
deviating from the protocol inside the
enclave thanks to you know there's
authenticated data structures the
enclaves have and things like this and
then for the storage like oram you can
easily have a merkle tree on top of it
and there's techniques like ariadne for
preventing rollback so these things
exist so i'm not going to go over them
right um the main thing that we're gonna
be concerned here is how to make sure
that the access patterns to memory and
storage
are not revealing any sensitive
information
okay so that's gonna be the focus the
rest is kind of you know it's been done
it's prior work
okay so about the clients
for simplicity in this talk assuming
that the clients are trusted they own
the data they just want to access it
without the server attacker learning
anything about their accesses but in our
work we talk about how you can have
malicious clients and how you can have
access control in the enclave
okay
any question about the setup before i go
into how we solve the scalability
problem and things like this
um and in terms of you know security
guarantees are going to be quite
standard and i'm not going to go into
them but basically oh a question sorry
yeah
um i was just wondering so do the client
like
do these clients compute the orm like
physical addresses or
does the enclave compute
oh good good point um so we will i will
show you how it works the system
actually works but here's just the
threat model which is uh we just
typically in crypto we just talk about
what kind of attacker model we have an
attacker model you have to keep in mind
is that the attacker sees everything at
this cloud that comes in and out of the
enclave goes to memory or inside the
storage system it says all the
ids that are being accessed that's
really just a threat model and then how
it works i'll tell you later
but the clients are just going to make
requests like you know get some id and
then gets the result back
so get input it's just the storage
system so just get input
okay and the security branches are going
to be very standard you know
in the simulation paradigm i'm not going
to go into them you can look into the
paper
um
okay
so here's the goal
we want to have a scalable oblivious
storage system
and let me explain what i mean by
scalability by taking the example of a
regular storage system that just has
you know data like object id object
value object id object value unencrypted
no security of any sort
so here you have users issuing many many
requests give me this uh object id gets
packed object put this object id gets
you know the value gets changed and so
forth thousands of them
now let's say that this server can
process at most a thousand requests per
second
well what you do in a regular storage in
that case if you want to go beyond let's
say you have millions of users right you
want to go to millions of requests per
second or whatnot
you're going to add another server
and what you're going to do is you're
going to partition the object id space
so the first object the first server is
going to have object ids starting with
zero blah blah assume you um you know
hash the ids so you take the first i
know bit if it's zero then you store the
objects at this server and if it's one
you store the objects at this other
server
so now users requesting kovid
are going to send the request to the
first server and users requesting you
know as mindful are going to go to
second server
and now if the second server has a
throughput of another thousand requests
per second it's quite nice because your
system can give you two thousand
requests per second
so what was really nice here is that we
added more the servers enhance the
throughput increased
okay so scalability means that as you
add more resources your throughput
increases
so we would like the same thing to
happen with oblivious storage right so
we can you know scale out to
large number of requests and you know
have the same thing from a secure system
as we have from their unstick insecure
system
the problem is that um
all existing storage systems have
scalability bottlenecks
and here's what i mean by it
uh let's take the example of tree based
oblivious storage systems and many of
them have this shape
so basically the storage of the server
is in the shape of a tree
and when the user requests something
like covid what's going to happen is
they're going to actually request a
random path in this tree
and it's random so that the attacker
doesn't really know what object is
actually requested
and
some word object will be on this path
and then this path also gets updated
the next time you have asthma
request is going to fetch another random
path in the tree and modify it and then
when you have flu another one and so
forth
so basically all the requests went
through the root
and the root is a scalability bottleneck
so if you have
this
node it's going to be at some server
that server can only process a certain
number of requests but all requests have
to go through that server some point the
server is you know is at maximum
capacity it doesn't matter what other
servers you add because all requests go
through that server and the server is a
scalability bottleneck
okay so this kind of structure is the
scalability bottleneck that's why you
know they couldn't scale beyond what the
server can service
okay
so looking back at the plaintext the
reason why it was scaling so well is
that we could send different requests to
different servers and proceed in
parallel but
that also leaks because now the attacker
can tell how many requests go to one
server versus another and again get some
sort of frequency information so again
it's some sort of high level access
pattern and in for oh there's lots of
requests going here probably covered is
here so then if charlie goes to you know
the doctor has copied and something from
here gets access charlie has copied
right so you still reveal some access
pattern so this is a tension because
what made us really scalable in the
plaintext space is what leaked success
patterns
right proceeding in parallel having
requests go to only one place where the
object is is what makes us be super
scalable because we proceed in parallel
but also that is what introduces the
leakage
okay so it's a pension here that's why
this was a question for a long time and
even i personally thought a lot about
this question how can we reconcile this
tension how can we have requests
proceeding parallel
but still have the guarantee of
obliviousness
namely that access patterns
gonna be independent or look independent
from
the object ids question
yeah very very good question so um i
didn't go into the details this is a
protocol called path or m
and i just kind of told you the high
level structure and why there's a
celebrity bottleneck
but to answer your question how pathogen
works is there is actually a mapping
between object id like covid and which
path which
path it is on and then the user would
know
and you know that mapping is also
scalability bottleneck because all
requests have to go through the node
that has that mapping so that's another
scalability bottleneck you know
yeah great question
um
but you don't need to understand more
details about how this key works because
the only character has bottlenecks
because our
design will be very different
all right um
so is it is it clear before i go on
what's the problem
why we have celebrity battle next and
okay why it's difficult to solve it
um so then
let's discuss about how we actually
build an oblivious object storage that
has high throughput and skills like a
plain text store
so um this is to give you a sense of
what snoopy achieves at the high level
um we have um
let's say if you have six enclaves in
snoopy you get 26 000 operations per
second so this is six unclip servers
if you double them then you're gonna get
72 000 questions per second
and the reason is not exactly double
it's it's uh
there's a reason for that and if you add
another six hardware uh enclave servers
you get
uh 130k right and the reason is not
exactly twice twice twice is because
actually we need four just to even
operate our system and then there's
different types of servers and they have
different effects on the scaling but you
get the point the more resources you add
you can keep increasing your throughput
with snoopy
and to compare with two state-of-the-art
systems in oblivion storage so bloody
they can process uh process six thousand
um almost seven thousand operations per
second and as you add more and more
servers that's it it stays back there it
cannot go on more because it doesn't
scale and another previous system by us
a thousand operations per second
right but for us you add more servers
you get more and more and more and more
operations per second
okay so how do we do that how do we do
that
so we're going to split
the server side into two types of
servers
load balancers
and suborams
the saborams they're each actually going
to have
a data partition just like in the plain
text case
so there's going to be um a bunch of
objects assigned to one of them a bunch
of objects to another and a bunch of
objects to another
and the way they're going to be assigned
is based on the kid hash
so basically from the
the attacker doesn't know what the
mapping is of object ids to partitions
it's going to be based on a kid hash an
attacker doesn't know the key
okay
now we're going to have these load
balancers
so basically each client is going to
send each request randomly to one of the
load balancers just completely random
with no
no not based on object id completely
random and that's safe thing to do from
an oblivious standpoint right because
it's not based on the object id
but then each load balancer is going to
wait for some epoch let's say a second
and get all the requests it receives in
that second
batch them and then is going to issue
requests to the suburbs
but
so for each of these things if you can
just store for example in the entire
duplication of the database can't you
already just assign people randomly to
different ones and be able to scale up
what's what's the problems thank you do
i think you're
one of the databases you have to go to
the others as well so then it's again a
scalability bottleneck
because you have to end up going to
every one of them so you want to be able
to proceed in parallel with both reads
and rights so for read only this is not
an interesting question for really only
this is you know it's so interesting for
it only yeah i have read only to this
pir
which is super paralyzable and super
i
scalable i probably wouldn't even use oblivious
tram although there is a work that has
read only only the sounded scales but
yeah
this is for rhythm right this is an
actual object storage where you have to
get template
yeah
good question okay so now if i have my
load balancers
you know have this batch of requests
and want to send it you know to the
respective
subworms that have those diseases
it's a problem because again it's going
to be some pattern of a leakage right
because if i uh send them based on the
object id it's going to be a different
number here versus here and again
there's going to be access patterns
leaking so we have to solve that problem
okay so here's how we solve the problem
well
again a helpful strawman is the
following so um
assume that
this each load balancer were to send
i don't know um
all the requests to each one of the
partitions
that would be secure right because it
sends the same number of requests and
all requests
to each suburum but that would not be
scalable because
then again you're not able to proceed
you're not able to proceed in parallel
between these partitions
okay
so instead here's a first idea first
idea is we're going to have
this load balancer
deduplicate
the request so if they all request
covered
it's going to obliviously we'll see how
a protocol for duplicating and having
only one request for kovid and then is
going to send the same number of
requests to each of the partitions
but this number has to be a
a number that's computed based on public
information it cannot be computed based
on how many distinct requests there are
because again you would be leaking
so it has to be computed based on public
information okay so what's public
information well public information is
the number of requests that even show up
at the cloud
that's something that comes outside of
the system just the number of requests
that's the public information other
public information is how many servers
you have how many partitions right the
attacker says this stuff
so based on this it should be entirely
predictable
how many requests we send at each
partition so that we don't reveal
any information through that batch size
and ideally we want that number to be
smaller much smaller than
the
total number of requests sent for
scalability
ideally you'd want it to be you know
number of requests divided by number of
saborams
but if you do that you might be in a
situation where you send more requests
to a saborum than that so you'll have to
drop some requests and that causes again
leakage if you drop request because
maybe the user retries and you see you
know timing and whatnot
okay so the question is
how are we going to set that batch size
and another insight besides the idea of
kind of duplicating this in an oblivious
way
is to take advantage of the fact that
this is a high throughput setting again
we use snoopy only in a situation where
you have a ton of requests if you have
rarely requests existing systems are
good enough because they're optimized
for latency being a low but if you have
a ton of offer load the tone of requests
then you can start realizing that okay
well naturally those tone of requests
are mostly going to distribute evenly
between the saborum so maybe our bound
for the batch size doesn't have to be
too large
so
here's what we're going to do
we're going to basically have a balls
and beans uh
approach right if the balls are the
requests that come in at the load
balancer and let's just focus on one
load balancer right now
you have a lot of requests coming in the
load balancer now these requests have
been duplicated by the load balancer
they're unique
we'll see later how to do that in an
oblivious way but assume they're unique
and there's lots of them
and you have these subordinates that
have assigned object ids randomly based
on a kid hash then you can expect that
your requests will distribute relatively
evenly across the different suburbs
so what you want is you want to set
a kind of a public function b
that depends on the number of requests
and the number of saborines
that will be always larger
with you know overwhelming probability
than how many requests will go into each
bin because you don't want to have
to drop a ball that causes leakage but
the same time will be much smaller
ideally than the number of requests
okay and then of course to fill up all
the way till the batch size you're gonna
add dummy requests okay just fake
requests to the oram so that it looks
like every oram is receiving
b number of requests
these are the dummy requests
and so we modeled this into a bulge into
beans problem and we were able to
contribute the bound b
that is actually quite close to an even
distribution
of these
balls into beans but the same time we
were able to prove
that with overwhelming probability
basically it's a negligible probability
that there will be an overflow in any
one of the bins
so
it's it's it's a bit of a
um
hairy analysis i won't go into it
but the point is that you can look into
the paper and we show that if you have
you know s aborams for any set of our
requests that are distinct and randomly
distributed over the suburbs for
security parameter lambda of your choice
then if you set the bound b to be this
the probability that the request will be
dropped is negligible in lambda
okay
so
of course the number of requests is
going to be quite small
then uh actually this number will be
quite large and you'll end up having
just
send the number of requests to each
suburb so it won't be interesting but if
the number of requests is large
actually this is going towards this
exponential term is going towards one so
you're going to have a even distribution
of requests involved in b so you're
actually going to have this scalability
okay and just to kind of uh give you
some intuition to this formula just um
you know empirical intuition
if the number of requests increases
uh let's say we have two suburums this
uh graph shows it to suburans then as
the number of requests increases you for
setting you know the security parameter
to be 128 you're gonna have less and
less dummies so this overhead shows you
the percentage that your dummy requests
because that's dummy request is wasted
work
and so as the number of requests
increases we're going to have less and
less uh wasted work right up to a
certain amount now if you have more
saborines you're going to have
percentage-wise more more wasted work
right because you have to pad all those
sample ranks intuitively
and then another uh graph here is like
is the number of saborium increases
then you are able to
have more capacity for real requests
right because you have more suburums
anyways you can play with this bound uh
and you can look at our paper and we
think that this bound in general is very
useful because maybe in other settings
as well would be applicable because it
only depends basically on the security
parameter here so the
probability of
you know a ball being dropped is
depending on the security parameter
and it's not does not depend for example
i mean it depends exponentially in a
security parameter and does not depend
it's not like a polynomial dependency
it's an actual
exponential you know negligible
probability
okay so now let's focus on
great so what are we doing with each
load balancer we know the batch size but
okay how are we actually implementing
obliviously this kind of the duplication
and distribution of requests at each
load balancer
okay so remember that we don't want to
reveal access patterns in that process
okay so here's what we want to do this
is the task
we have a load balancer let's focus on
one
we know the batch size from that
previous analysis okay
and what we want to do is we get a lot
of requests from users we want to the
duplicates remove duplicates
okay we don't do this obliviously
again the attacker sees all our accesses
to memory so you can't just go you know
i'll show you in a moment what we can do
but then we will also distribute them
per sub or m based on the kid hash
function
and then get the requests back and match
them back to the original you know
requests and send them to the user
so i'm going to tell you two building
blocks and then we're going to build
this load balancer algorithm from these
two building blocks
so we're using an oblivious sort
algorithm
which basically takes
some values and can sort them
in an oblivious way so this is a
building block we're using
um for example in this case we're using
a battery network
and this comes with a proof that you
know if you make accesses according to
this algorithm the attacker cannot tell
anything about you know which item went
where which object went where okay it's
an oblivious sort
now we're also going to use an oblivious
compaction
where basically we have some items and
we want to keep delete delete keep
delete okay
so this oblivious compaction algorithm
it's more efficient than because you
could obviously do this with an
oblivious sort
um but it's more efficient it's going to
basically sort them based on what you
keep uh and what you don't keep
and you can actually easily discard
these two as long as the amount that you
keep is a number that's known by the
taco tucker-like public based on public
information
so basically we have these two building
blocks they're simple one we can sort
obliviously and one is we can compact
obliviously
so now let's try to together
figure out what the load balancer has to
do
okay so here's what these are a number
of requests set of requests that are
coming in at the load balancer
as you can see there's like a duplicate
there's a duplicate the first and the
last
and then there's a few other distinct
ones and so we're going to do a first
pass when we're going to assign
basically what just going to do one scan
we're going to sign based on the key
hash to which sabor am is supposed to go
and assume we have two subordinates okay
so first one is supposed to go to the
first suburb second the second first
first first
so
i want to hear you know thoughts from
you but just to tell you a little bit
more again what we want to do is we want
to send
the ones that are assigned to one to the
first subworm and the ones that are
assigned to the second to the second
saborim and we want to remove this
duplicate
and we want to do this obliviously so we
cannot make accesses of the sort
um oh
this is one i'm gonna do it the sun is
the first suburban oh this is two i'm
going to send it to second sabor oh this
goes to the first and first and first
because attacker can see our accesses
can see we took the first object send it
to the first aborium the second goes to
the second the third goes to the first
so again it's going to see our access
and infer you know information about our
object ids
so the axis has to be either
random looking or it has to be according
to predefined schedule
so any ideas what we could do so we have
an oblivious sort ability to sort
obliviously and the ability to
basically um compact obliviously so kind
of discard some elements based on a
filter
any ideas what we could do
yeah you can add a bunch of gummies so
that you don't have you don't reveal
literally one thing is label two
and then you sort it no you type compact
to move all the ones and the twos and
what not and then you sort source
yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly exactly so
first we're going to add a bunch of
dummies
we're gonna how many diamonds are we
gonna add again it has to be a
predefined number
uh based on public information it cannot
be based on what objects ideas we
actually have so let's say that each
suburum can take
text b
you know the b is certainly three okay
then we add three dummies
um for the first sub or i mean freedom
is for the second saburam again b is
known by the attacker so what we did
here is completely as expected by the
attacker
okay
now exactly what's your name syria
syria
oh surya yeah okay thank you surya so
exactly as surya said we're now going to
sort this the reason we're going to
store them is because we want to group
together all the items that go to the
first saborem and the items that go to
the second saborim
okay so we're going to obliviously sort
them and now they're nicely grouped
together
nicely good together so now we want to
get rid of duplicates
right so what uh
what are we going to do and to get rid
of duplicates
again without the topic because we can't
go and say oh keep this and then cut
this one you know delete it and then
keep like if the attacker will figure
out oh this whatever was the first
object it's kind of duplicate it's
duplicated right has two occurrences
any thoughts what we could do to
get rid of
the duplicates and then also
kind of prepare our batches for the
different orams
yeah amy uh do the compaction and
keep
like the
enough w so both of the groups are the
same right right exactly yeah so
basically first we're going to do a scan
to kind of figure out what to keep and
what not to keep so we're going to do
one scan against cancer oblivious
because you just scan things
you know nothing based on id so we're
gonna see this and say oh object 34 okay
we keep it the mind we stand next and oh
it's a repeat so no this will not be
kept
um but again this bit here
it's encrypted the attacker cannot tell
what it is we haven't removed anything
yet
and then this one keep keep
and then we realized okay there's been
enough ones there's been three ones and
we only want to send three to a saborim
so we're going to say remove remove
remove but again we keep them we just
mark them as removed and then the same
thing for two okay keep then oh we need
to keep two more dummies because we need
to get to three and then remove okay and
now we just do an oblivious compaction
which is basically going to sort out the
ones to keep atop and the ones to not
leave at the bottom it's okay to get rid
of the ones not to keep white because
the tucker knows exactly how many things
we're going to get rid of
why because we're going to send the
items to each of our so tucker knows
exactly how many you're going to get rid
of you could read them okay and now it's
simple you take the first three sentence
to the first aborium the second three
send them to the second sabor i mean you
can do that because attacker expects you
to do that expects to take the first
ones and the first abortion second
second and so forth right so you see why
all of this has been done in a way that
attacker has no clue how many items were
duplicates how many items went to the
first subway or the second samurai
and at the same time we're only sending
priests aboard
much less than the number of requests so
they can actually proceed in parallel
and computing parallels which you know
is key to scalability
because you can add more and more
subordinates and have more throughput
and then okay so once the subordinates
reply with the object content
you have to match it back to those
requests some requests will be
duplicated there's some work you have to
do but that's in the paper okay so it's
kind of the reverse of what we've done
um and i'm not going to go through that
okay
so the last piece so you still have the
load balancers work now let's focus on
what happens with the submarines
no question yeah i have a question so in
blossom-based analysis it seems that it
assumes that these cures are distributed
uniformly to each of them but it doesn't
seem to be the case uh in the algorithm
new show
so for example if i like if there are
three points and two of them i will
access the first one and
it's like specific
so how do they think it's a very good
question very good question so actually
what happens is that
the um object ids are assigned randomly
to each sub oram
and the requests are going to be
duplicated when they're sent out to the
saborum so you're only going to have
distinct requests so for example if we
go back uh this click doesn't
work um
but yeah that's a good question that's
kind of key
um
let me just go really quickly through
this so these are going to be the
requests that we end up sending
so we're going to be all the duplicated
so they're going to be only unique
values
but now yes the requests are not random
because the users made them
but the assignment of objects to
subordinates is according to a kid hash
that's random and unknown to the
attacker so they are random
yeah great question
yeah
so if all the objects were the same
right that they were all like 34 then
the attacker would say you only send one
request to each server right because
good question so actually if uh there
were only 34 this would be dummy and
dummy you still send three are you still
sentry yeah you still simply because you
only send this this batch size b and b
depends only on the number of requests
that show up and not on whether they're
duplicates or distinct yeah so you
always still send that b now b depends
only on how many requests you have that
arrive
but not whether they duplicate or not
yeah great question
okay um so okay so now let's do you know
let's see how the last piece of the
system works the sub ram
and already if you were to just use a
regular or um
you are able to proceed in parallel so
you already solved the scalability
bottleneck
but here we're actually going to propose
a different orange and one one that
exists
because in this setting we can actually
do much more efficiently than what
exists
why
well because
we um
existing work prioritizes latency not
throughput but in this setting we have a
lot a lot of requests that are coming in
so we have a batch at each sabor and we
have a batch of requests that we have to
service at the same time so let's take
advantage of the fact that there's a
bunch batch sorry a batch of values
instead of just one at a time
and just take advantage of the fact that
these are distinct requests okay so with
each suburb we get a batch of distinct
requests
and this is a great something that we
can definitely leverage with oblivious
storage why because what's typically
hard in oblivious algorithms is when
values repeat because that's when
frequency leaks intuitively and a lot of
what the aura does is to kind of prevent
that observation at something repeated
so now if we have a large batch of
requests that are distinct
it sounds like we can do way better than
the regular orem and we can so actually
it turns out that
signal
has an algorithm that is kind of
intuitively
going the direction of what we want
how many of you use signal so it's great
a lot of you use signal yeah great so
it's i know if you knew but basically
what signal does when you join signal
when you have a new contact
what it does is it wants to do an
intersection obviously with the signal
user so these are signal users at the
server and these are your contacts
and signal wants to figure out who is
common so they can tell you your friend
is on signal and if you get those
annoying notifications this person your
friend is on signal i hate them
but
you know that this is what's happening
so they do kind of it's a set
intersection right of the contacts and
um the signal list but the way they do
it is they actually do it with enclaves
and oblivious computation in the cloud
so basically what happens you take the
contacts they don't want to they don't
want to go for every contact and look it
up because it's too slow
to do that or am for that so instead
they're taking advantage of the fact
that there's uh maybe thousands of
contacts and they're distinct right your
contact list is distinct
so it's similar to kind of what we want
right so what they do is they're going
to put in an oblivious hash table this
contacts and then they're going to do
one scan through all the signal users
and in that scan is going to look it up
in the hash table see if it shows up or
not
and so with one scan through all the
signal users is going to
figure out whether all these c contacts
are there or not in one scan okay so
it's like a batch processing here
and this is much more efficient in
realistic terms than doing
oram which auram is you know has fully
logarithmic overhead for every request
and this is going to be you know linear
divided by c but still in real terms
it's far more efficient than doing the
orm uh because of the constants of the
orm
okay so this is what they do and this
sounds okay what we want because the
context in signal can be our requests
and this list of signal users is the
list of objects of an uh sabori okay so
now our saborium can do what signal is
doing for a batch of requests and be
much much more efficient than you know
doing a regular oblivious ram like
pathoram for every one of these requests
but there's actually two problems
one problem is that
their
hash table is still kind of slow when
you have you know hundreds of thousands
tens of thousands of requests
because they were fine we see squared
for a user's contacts but we're having
even more requests than that in our
system
but the other problem is also that we
actually found the security issue in
their protocol in that basically what
happens is they have buckets in this
oblivious hash table they didn't size
accordingly and you have overflow over
those buckets and when you do that you
basically have leakage
so
basically what you could do is you could
say okay so you have these buckets and
you can
size the buckets based on how many
objects mapped there which is similar to
what happens in signal when you have an
overflow but that's leakage because
if some object hashed to a big bucket
it's more likely to um
be requested than not try to be in the
contact lease than not
so because you get this overflow of
buckets and signal there's actually
leakage and they're not fully oblivious
um
okay so we instead want to have a bucket
size
that is fixed always and you don't get
overflow
this sounds familiar
it's again the problem we had at the
load balancer showing up here at the sub
orm
so
we could actually use our bucket our way
of choosing the
batch size for this scenario as well
but it actually uh turns out that the
buckets would be a little bit large
uh it works it's uh you know oblivious
and secure
but it actually turns out that the
buckets are a little bit large and we
can actually do something
better or something easier something
faster is we can use a data structure by
chana tal an to tier hash table
which
make sure that the overflow buckets are
put in a second
hash table
and that will result in smaller buckets
and i'm not going to go into this result
you can go and read it but intuitively
because you have a second tier second
level of the hash table
you for the overflow you're able to get
much smaller buckets
um and so this is going to be result in
a much smaller much much more efficient
scan through each bucket because the
buckets are going to be smaller
and actually we talked to signal people
about this and we told them about you
know the security issue and about how to
solve it and so they're in the they were
anyways in the process of revamping
their protocol so
hopefully they will include our ideas
but they're aware of the security issue
okay so um right
so basically this gave you a high level
of
how snoopy works in the time that i had
and so i told you how you have
obliviously duplication
and distribution of the batches at the
load balancers
how we chose this batch
size to be basically um
based on public information in using
these balls and beans analysis that you
can see more about in the paper
and that's smaller than sending all
requests at once aboard them so that
really gives you the ability to paralyze
and be efficient
and then i told you how we have the
basically the sub ram design inspired
from the signal protocol but using a
two-tier hash table instead
and you can see more details of that in
the paper
and the final bit um that you can see in
the paper and just mentioned the high
level is we have a planner why well
figuring out okay i have
a million requests per second figuring
out how many load balancers versus
how many suburums to have it's an
optimization problem
and so we have a planner that basically
outputs a system configuration you tell
the tell the planner i want to service
this many requests per second
um and some upper bound in your latency
and it can compute how many suborams and
how many how many load balancers you
need to optimally achieve that
and of course we have um security formal
security and linearizability proofs uh
for consistency and for security yeah
question
yeah so the planner does it is it
something that like you would just do
once at the beginning or could you like
kind of you know create a system that
has similar balances into some orm and
then later say like okay now i want to
add like one or the other and change
dynamically oh that's interesting it's
interesting yeah in our case you do it
at the beginning but it's actually um
your name is alita yeah okay
um so um
it's a very good question and i think it
could be interesting uh next step to
look into how to dynamically adjust
while being oblivious right because
don't want to just say okay i'm adding
another board and give me this piece and
you want to you want to do it in a
careful way
uh but right now we're just having it at
the beginning
the nice thing about the low balancer
those are the easiest you can just throw
in a new one
just adding one white because a lot of
balancers are completely independent of
each other they don't have to stay they
just get a bunch of requests
they you know compute the batch size
based number of requests and distribute
the obligations to those requests and
then after that you don't keep anything
in mind so you can spin them up and down
very easily the subwoofer and you want
to be a bit more careful in when you add
a sabor and mystery
workload yeah
it shouldn't be too difficult
yeah i guess if multiple people try to
write to the same index then an
arbitrary one wins yes absolutely so we
have um guarantees on thailand going
through linearizability and basically
what happens is a load balancer can
choose the order
of the request that it gets
um and you can choose which put wins
yeah and a lot of these uh scalable
object stories even for plaintext don't
have very strong have this kind of
consistency guarantees anyways yeah good
question
in the server or like across
the reveals the reveals that lalit asked
about
yeah so basically the saborium is the
one that's kind of like a norm for a
partition and the saburam is the one
that's going to
basically uh whenever you have a put is
going to update that value and yes
there's a shuffle going with every scan
there's a shuffle happening that will
be a source that will basically update
the value that gets put
yes with every batch of course it
happens absolutely and as i mentioned
the reason is that we have so many
requests so many queries that in one
basically you're scanning obviously sort
we're able to you know update and
service the requests and we prefer the
complexity to be linear
uh than to be logarithmic times the
number of requests because there's so
many requests
and the constants of pathogen or the
like tree like structures are high so
this is much more efficient to kind of
do a scan and oblivious sort for that
many requests
they won't have that much storage you
can't expect a user to have that much
storage because the batches are huge and
then like yeah yeah honestly there's all
these works that say oh you can have the
oram client in the
in some trusted place where is a trusted
place who gives it to you know you know
think about pragmatics you know as a
systems builder and you know having
companies
where is it where is it gonna go who
should i run that for you know
especially when you have my users well
i'm gonna put it on the cloud well if
you put it on the cloud and you trust
the cloud might as well run your whole
storage there right
so yeah uh
it could be an application in the cloud
yeah
and you only need to have a method for
pieces that handle the key and the
comparing swap and things like this you
don't need to have indiana the actual
storage that can be outside the entire
then fetched in and out
questions okay so really quickly i'm
just gonna go through the evaluation so
um slope is open source
and you can find our implementation here
and also this was published at the
security conference sosp systems
conferences osp and the next thing that
this usb has is optionally they can
evaluate your open source artifact and
um they basically give you badges if
they manage to you know make sure that
it's functional has all the
functionality you promised and also the
results were reproduced so we got those
badges basically the reviewers were able
to reproduce our results based on open
source and check the functionality of
our system so feel free to use it build
on it improve it and what not give us
feedback
okay so uh in terms of evaluation i'm
just going to show you an evaluation on
18 major machines on azure azure has
enclaves which is great
and i'm going to compare to two
state-of-the-art systems oblation
obliques which have the scalability
bottleneck
so you can see that as you add more
machines or bloody and obliques just
stay put at the throughput because they
um at this throughput they've basically
filled up to capacity their server uh
their bottleneck server and they're
unable to scale but with snoopy let's
say you batch for one second so you bet
for one second
you can have you know as you add more
machines you have an increase in
throughput
um if you batch for
um half a second
then you have still an increasing
throughput but the throughput is going
to be less right because for more
requests you have the more balancing
we're able to do between the saborines
the less dummies we're going to have the
more efficient our saborine protocol
will be and so forth but of course you
can't choose this batch epoch i mean
that
while you batch to be too large because
that affects your latency right you have
to wait for that much when you send a
request to get you know all those
requests in in a second you have to wait
for a second so
the more latency you're able to tolerate
the more throughput we can give you
because you can batch more requests
okay so to conclude snoopy is an
oblivious
object store that scales like a plain
text storage that kind of
that kind of curve is what you want to
see what you see in a plain text storage
and what you now get to see also in our
oblivious
storage system
and yeah you can read more uh in our
paper or you can look at our open source
and um yeah thank you
the space um
i don't think there's many uh i would
say uh figure out the way that you don't
increase the latency
but have the throughput scaling
but without having you know increased
latency that much because right now uh
if you take pathology an existing gram
system they have that related see than
smokey has for just
for a low support scenario right we just
get a request here and there they're
much more efficient than us we are
education when you have a ton of
requests and we just want to scale
instead of scale
so it would be nice to see if one can
have balls
low latency
it cannot be very very interesting
what is the asymptotic overhead is it
blocks squared
so it's linear
divided by the number of requests
and actually in the oram and pir
literature in the past years has been a
number of words that are saying forget
about the poliographic like pathogram
you know go for linear because it's more
efficient because the constants matter
and the constant is very large
with oram compared to just a quick scan
and servicing multiple requests so
you're basically going to look look at
every like all the content
yes exactly but if you do want to have a
little bit of make overhead and still
scale
you can still use our load balancer
algorithms
and our batch site selection but have a
regular orange poly algorithm into the
suburus and then you have poly
algorithmic overhead and you still have
the triple scaling you still don't have
the bottleneck
this kind of our suburban design is kind
of an addition
because we noticed that if you have lots
of requests in there um this thing can
do much something much more efficient in
terms of concrete costs
but it's not the the linear again you
can have followers
yeah
um so
when when you're making the same number
of requests
you can kind of fundamentally delete
that oh ram is being used
um
would it adapt do you think to any sort
of arbitrary distribution right if you
wanted to like add it like not sit one
and sort of skew the distribution
to make it look like you have more
requirements with that adaption system
like this or would that kind of
introduce more challenges than it was
so i don't know if i understood the
question
well but i think the question is if the
distribution is really secured you have
a ton of some disease and less of
another
then whether this would be secure would
have to change adapt
the system won't adapt to that so um
we are all believers which means that no
matter how special distribution is
the same behavior happens
yeah i see
i mean in principle you put hydra to
using orange right by having some sort
of generic
system right
universal circuit style thing
what it is just doing
but there's just been much much much
much more requests right you have to
define and windows operation that does i
don't know
that's you know touch a certain amount
of data there's a certain amount of
reading and through that unit of
operations you can probably implement
something
like this or like or i'm probably very
very slow but in first of all yeah you
can
the other thing that you might want to
hide is how many requests arrive at the
cloud so then is the secure messaging
literature has
situations where you just use a
constantly sending request and obviously
the page is very slow
so i feel like i'm not understanding
something so let's say like the there
are many servers with like people who
want to write at requests but like
everyone wants read requests to like
particular
sabora does that mean the number of
dummy added it's like linear in terms of
the number of separate that's a good
question the question is let's say
everybody requests the same disease and
we discuss this example in the beginning
and so then will this massive number of
requests all go to one uh saborium and
then you have to add dummies to the
others the answer is no because the
whole like crucial actual insight of our
work was to duplicate these requests so
when they show up with the load balancer
we basically duplicate the same disease
requesting lunch times we only make one
request once agora when you get the
response back and multiplex it as a
response to all these requests and that
was really i would say a really crucial
insight that enabled
us to do this work and have scalability
yeah exactly otherwise you'll run into
that problem of having a ton of requests
absolutely
i think i'm yeah over time
but i'm also happy to chat last night
it's time for one
i had great questions really appreciated
and involved yeah
right request just said then the other
one bounces i mean one gets through yeah
but if you have everybody writes the
same like you having put your
uh aggregation the action period for too
long and everybody is like this is the
favorite thing to write you
wouldn't you just like totally linearize
this and make it super slow
also wouldn't that leak information on
how often you
actually have the same access
yes a good uh point so each um each load
balancer is going to wait for requests
for certain amount of spine right and
can decide which foot means among the
requests
and then what happens is that um the
subforums are giving the small chunk
working chunks in netflix
and each epoch is for one load balancer
then the next type book is for the other
low balance so next
ones and so forth
okay so
it's only a problem if two arrive at the
same load balancer yeah exactly two
arrive at the same location one is gonna
be overwritten yeah
absolutely
it's